hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my gaming channel where we also talk
about movies sometimes today I'm talking
about Bobby I am a little bit late
um because I got a new pc and it died so
here we are the webcam quality looks
worse than it did in the last video
my PC died so Barbie
I overall did not like this film very
much though there are things in it that
I liked a lot so let's start with those
I think the performances across the
board were incredible uh Ryan Gosling
certainly stole the show but I also
thought that simileo and Margot Robbie I
mean everyone everyone in this film I
thought was uh super fun to watch with
maybe the exception of of the teenage
girls
also I guess before we go any further I
am just going to talk about spoilers in
this one because it's kind of too hard
to not talk about it like I would much
prefer to review this movie full
spoilers than to uh avoid them so
spoilers spoilers spoilers uh spoilers
spoilers I also thought that the uh I
think Michael Sarah and Will Ferrell
were like absolutely hilarious
um probably like some of my favorite
performances from those two in general I
don't know if I somehow missed it in the
trailer but I didn't know Will Ferrell
was even in the movie and I found him to
be very funny and there were plenty of
laugh out loud moments across the board
most of which I think were like
certainly partly from the script but a
lot from performances I found like
honestly Ken Ryan Gosling I just can't
imagine anyone doing a better job than
he did of that particular character the
costuming set design production uh all
of that stuff was really exciting to see
so different from everything else that's
in cinemas right now clearly a lot of
attention to detail I love how there are
so many like little facets of of Bobby
that were included like the fact that
the shower didn't have any water in it
Bobby's fridge was mostly 2D except for
the milk that she poured and it didn't
work so clearly the places where money
was spent on this movie I think they did
a very very very good job a really good
soundtrack if I remember correctly as
well however
I don't think this this one even needs
to be that long my thoughts are kind of
simple I saw a lot of people say they
were confused by the marketing or they
felt misled like they expected this to
be a comedy and it wasn't I do not feel
misled I expected this this movie to
have some kind of political message
basically because it's critical awake uh
who was writer director car writer
director but I definitely expected it to
have something to say that was
surprising and I think because of the do
you guys ever think about deathline in
the trailer I expected existential
crisis maybe some commentary on like
where we exist what our purpose is
outside of the brands that we uh attach
to like maybe some kind of nostalgia
commentary I was expecting something
more along those lines than what was
actually in the movie but I did not feel
at all misled I expected this movie to
to have something to say
um
I guess I could say I was misled my
criticism is ultimately that I think it
was very confused in what it was trying
to say and if the the takeaway of the
film is supposed to be something like uh
women don't have to be perfect I feel
like that's like a thing that I knew was
like a 13 year old but it really gives
us a lot of commentary and doesn't stay
consistent with a thread I think some
cases it's actually messaging gets
confused because it is obsessed with
references that people don't understand
like um when Bobby goes to the high
school and is basically just like
attacked by a group of young girls for
the way that she looks that that seemed
very odd to me because uh in theory you
would be painting the young girls as the
progressives here especially when
Bobby's just like been harassed and cat
called in Venice Beach
to have young women treated that way as
well as a strange choice but I guess
they did that because those women uh was
supposed to emulate Bratz dolls each of
their names is the same as the names of
the four main Bratz dolls but like so
few people would know that I feel like I
don't know maybe there's a huge market
for people who know the names of the
Bratz dolls enough to like figure out
that they were Bratz dolls and that's
maybe why they were being mean to Bobby
I don't know which leads us into my
second problem is
um that young girl I think her name was
Sasha a huge issue with this movie is I
don't even actually remember the names
of the two additional characters who are
like plot B the mother and daughter nor
do I really understand what they wanted
the B plot is in theory a
mother-daughter story trying to bring
those two back together resolve their
conflicts but it felt a lot more to me
like it was just a way to justify why
things were suddenly changing for Bobby
which still doesn't even really make
sense why why every time that I question
anything I'm like maybe this isn't the
movie to be questioned and this is a me
problem that I need need the plot to
make sense I don't know but why would
the executive assistant at Mattel
writing
things or I don't even know if she's an
executive assistant I know she wasn't
like a toy designer
just like writing things on a piece of
paper
influence
Bobby
you know but it did alas uh Bobby starts
getting cellulite which is also a weird
one for a supposedly feminist movie that
again they're acting like that it's the
literal worst thing that could happen to
a woman even though it happens to most
humans and that like our protagonist is
crying for two hours about that so then
you know she's like terrified of a flat
feet I have flat feet and has to go to
the real world to find out what's wrong
with the woman who owns her that's
causing these problems which is where
Ken learns about the patriarchy which is
referenced so many times in this movie
and realizes that it's awesome and that
he should take it back
um which is like also kind of a
confusing stance because I don't
actually know who the villain
necessarily is in this film if you live
in a society that is like 100 women
controlled all the women are in the
Senate women are running everything and
the men are just accessories which in
theory is a suggestion that that is a
flip on the real world which it
obviously isn't why would Ken not see
that and want to take that like wouldn't
that make sense if you're oppressed so I
get why he had that reaction I also
think taking the what is seen as the
patriarchy and um boiling it down to
horses and beer and all the women were
so happy in Bobby land too like nobody
seemed upset about it at all we got done
horses and beer are great there are
things that that women face that are
real problems that I feel like this
movie uh did not comment on at all
instead like posing the problems is like
men like horses
and like oh I want to be a mom but I
also want to be this and I maybe I want
to be that is like that's a human
experience not a female experience there
are things that I think are part of the
female experience and things that are
part of the male experience that are
unique problems that I think we should
absolutely explore film is a great place
to do that I would post that like GTA 5
is a very uh masculine story I love that
story but it's a it's a story exploring
things like like pressure and adversity
that seems specific to a male experience
Bobby presents uh the Barbie land the
place where women rule
and everybody's perfect and happy
it's such an odd take and then Ken's
response again makes sense to me and
then even then the women's plan that
Bobby's plan to like stop the Takeover
of the cans is to like trick and
manipulate them and not let them have
power and at least at the end Bobby's
like you're right you're not just Ken it
doesn't have to be gold side every night
so she recognizes that the equality is
the ideal outcome but getting there is
strange and even then like I don't know
it feels weird but all the people that I
see uh comment on this movie like it
seems like it hates men the men in this
movie were hilarious and when they were
supposed to turn on each other they
instead ended up dancing they were so
fun to watch
um and so much funnier than a lot of the
female characters that I feel like the
movie the spotlight was effectively
taken by Ryan Gosling he was way more
fun to watch than Margot Robbie who
cried for two hours like I saw that
people were trying to suggest that the
Mattel boardroom were all the way that
they were because the movie thinks Mana
stupid
um I took that as the movie trying to
paint Capital CEO board rooms as a
negative and that's why they brought in
the character who was the original
creator of Bobby and now she had like a
ghost floor or whatever and I think that
might be one of my bigger criticisms uh
of the film in general and why it was
probably never going to sit right with
me is like you can
try and talk to me about how women are
asked to be too many things and oh women
are asked to be perfect
um but it's just rings so obviously true
that what you're really trying to do
with the movie is so much nice I think
maybe I have trouble switching off that
part of my brain and so it makes me view
it with a lot more cynicism than I think
a lot of the people who came out of it
with the pleasant experience and that
again is on me that I felt like I was
just hyper aware of the fact that Patel
wanted this to make as much money as
possible and they wanted to sell as much
merchandise as possible and now there's
a Mattel Cinematic Universe a new MCU
and so they just you know said some
really boring stuff and and made some
jokes and made a pretty set like even
the stuff that I like it's just I just
have trouble
not seeing that part of it the bumbling
idiots in the boardroom were very funny
um they're like not knowing how to do
the swipe card I found to be very
entertaining but then you kind of take
my enjoyment of those jokes away from me
when I'm aware that like that's kind of
the reality of a brand like Bobby I had
this issue with certain scenes where
they were saying things that were
supposed to be emotional or empowering
maybe
um and it was very fluffy and didn't
really say anything but they put nice
soft lighting and a Dramatic Song behind
it so that it would make people feel
emotional I just don't think it said
anything in the mess of trying to figure
out if it was something that had a
message or was a comedy the comedy Parts
I thought were very funny I'm gonna be
honest asking a bunch of dudes to play
guitar to distract them is very funny to
me I really thought Will Ferrell and
Michael Sarah were hilarious
um but I I guess like I wish that it had
just been the comedy that I guess a lot
of people felt like they were tricked by
I expected it to have a message I think
its message doesn't make any sense it
was really messy and like what are you
saying like if the if Bobby land was so
great and you could have brought quality
there why did the movie end with Margot
Robbie just going to the place that has
the patriarchy anyway and the first
thing she does is go to a gynecologist
like the first thing you do is a real
woman quote unquote is
go to a gynecologist
if she wanted to go to the real world to
help girls why the [__] would it end on
that note the young girl Sasha was very
anti-bobby and then for no reason turned
and was like we gotta go to Bobby land I
just feel like as soon as I question the
plot
I don't
have a lot of straight answers which is
my own fault and I know that if I had
just gone in and was like I'm here for a
fun time let's enjoy Bobby then I
probably would have enjoyed it a lot
more uh that is on me uh that I am maybe
taking a movie not meant to be taken
that seriously because it's literally
about a children's toy uh a little a
little too seriously but yes that is
ultimately my take I did see it a week
ago at this point so sorry if I've
gotten some details wrong I've forgotten
some things I wish I could have recorded
this today off my pc didn't work um I
just know that
yeah when I came out I was like Wow
amazing production design uh set design
call streaming all of that was
absolutely incredible I loved the
performances there were things that I
found laugh out loud funny but I also
just felt like it was like very muddy
and messy and like contradicted its own
point
or didn't know what its own point was
several times like the existential dread
Bobby do you ever think about death
thing so many interesting things you can
say with that that aren't at all tied to
Bobby stereotypical Bobby as they call
her nor the woman who drew that that
that means absolutely nothing in this
film it's just kind of that and like
being like Oh women get cellulite and
they shouldn't be judged for that
certainly
um but that's not like an interesting
take you know I don't know again I'm
aware that I'm an outlier and most
people love this movie um I respect it
and I wish that I did I just felt like
it was a muddy script that gave me more
questions than anything
and I think I was just disappointed that
it didn't either stick cohesively to one
through line
um a stronger one that that maybe would
have had more of an impact rather than
something that just felt like a little
bit cheesy or wafty to me or would have
just gone Full comedy I would have
preferred probably just full comedy and
like isakai with Bobby ending up in the
real world great communicable
opportunities there so yes things I
liked About It ultimately think my
issues are more with the script than
anything else and that maybe if I went
in with different expectations I would
feel differently and I'm sure that that
is a big part of it is I just was
probably expecting too much
that's on me